the first thing i would say is that i've
i'm always disappointed by other
people's scenarios of the future this is
a game that many people who lecture play
and
it's always disappointing to me like to
see great men like arthur c clarke or
someone like that and then to realize
that actually the future they envision
seems very pedestrian because the real
the real factors which will shape the
future are probably unpredictable highly
uncertain
what i see happening is
that more and more this coral reef
quality
of humanness
asserting itself as we become more and
more to identify with our the products
of our technology this is happening at
one level and and then in very
highly
stratified and dense urban situations
where everything is artificial it's like
that aesthetic which would turn the
whole world into
an international airport a rival
terminal you know and you see this
happening in the internationalization
and leveling of architectural styles all
to serve the constraints of
of capitalism essentially of the
delivery of the largest amount of space
for the least expenditure of money
i think very quickly that level of
cultural is going to of culture is going
to be transcended
and the restriction
on the availability of goods and
services which has been the thing which
has always before sort of constrained
the historical situation is going to be
obviated and there will be the
materialist paradise that
the 19th century
and 18th century mercantilists dreamed
of
but
at the same time
[Music]
this
the this discovery of the interior world
is going to loom
much larger because people are
essentially creatures of information and
i invoked for you earlier today these
enormous structures
which will be placed into space
it's possible to imagine you know
a radio signal propagated from earth
within 12 light hours reaches further
than the outer orbit of pluto
it's also it's already been demonstrated
in that the engineering is possible to
create a hawaiian type
climate in a space colony with mirrors
up to six light months from the sun
in other words that at six light months
from the sun you could have the climate
essentially of the kona coast
this means that the actual sphere of
potential human habitation is now one
light year in diameter
with the sun at its center i'm sure that
we won't occupy a sphere that large but
a sphere 12 light hours in diameter
would mean that a news event happening
somewhere in the solar system would
happen everywhere in the solar system
within that news day
so that in other words uh
mars and uranus are really no fur would
really be no further away than beirut or
djibouti or someplace like that
and the galaxy of
human cultures which science fiction
dished up for us in the 50s and the 60s
could actually be accomplished not
in the 60 000 light years required for
the volume of a galaxy but in 12 light
hours
because these
l5 type space colonies that are going to
be created are going to be sociological
microcosms each one
working out the kind of society that it
wants for itself
each spatially isolated from the others
but embedded in an aura of
electromagnetic information transfer
that actually creates
a global solar system type culture
this is going to happen this is the low
end of the prophecy scale this is the
hardware stuff that is inevitable
we know that the processing of lunar
materials the capture of solar energy
the building of solar sails and skates
the possibility of
actually super high strength materials
creating direct transfer of material
from earth to orbit
all these things are going to happen the
question that is interesting to me is
what kind of people
you know oh brave new world that has
such people in it what kind of people
will these people be who are
the inheritors and creators of that kind
of civilization and i think the answer
is obvious that they will be psychedelic
that the i think it's mercilead who in
talking about the magical flight motif
in shamanism says whatever we may think
of magical flight the continuous
projection of a self-transforming human
image of spatial ascendance speaks
volumes about the inherent dreams of the
human soul
in other words there actually is built
in to this arboreal monkey to this once
arborial monkey the wish to ascend
it is
associated with safety
and rightly so because a sufficient
ascent will break our genome off
from the fate of the planet and we'll
not only break our genome off from the
state of the planet but we'll take with
us
the thousands and thousands of species
of plants and animals that we have woven
into the fabric of
the biological freightage of our
civilization
[Music]
you